[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv 78 sur
radio sensations également pour ce débat
dans le cadre de l'élection législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines à l'issue du premier tour
dimanche dernier est scrutin marqué par
une très faible participation de
candidats sont en ballottage philippe
benassaya mer les républicains de bois
d'arcy conseiller départemental des
yvelines et sandrine grand gant
maire-adjointe génération de trappes
conseillère régionale d'île de france
les deux candidats qui sont en plateau
bonjour à tous et bienvenue elle les
électeurs des communes donc de bois
d'arcy elancourt fontenay le fleury la
verrière le mesnil saint denis saint cyr
l'école et rap vont devoir se prononcer
ce dimanche 27 septembre pour les aider
à choisir qui de vous deux ils vont être
envoyés à siéger à l'assemblée
nous allons aborder deux thématiques au
cours de la prochaine demi heure
philippe benassaya vous avez choisi de
parler de sécurité sandrine grand groupe
vous souhaitez évoqué l'environnement
nous avons procédé à un tirage au sort
juste avant le début de ce débat et nous
débutons donc par l'environnement
l'environnement c'est l'un des chantiers
est les plus importants du gouvernement
preuve en est le plan de relance
comporte un volet à 30 milliards d'euros
pour la transition écologique pour
autant les mesures annoncées
développement du ferroviaire ou encore
baisse des impôts de production à
hauteur de 10 millions par an ne font
pas l'unanimité sandrine gang pour vous
la politique menée actuellement manière
matière d'environnement n'est pas la
bonne
elle répond simplement au lobby c'est ce
que vous dites cirque on a eu beaucoup
d'effet d'annoncé suite à la convention
citoyenne qui était une bonne idée
l'idée de faire participer les citoyens
à la réflexion de ce que doivent être
les politiques demain c'était
intelligent mais simplement ça débouche
sur rien dire que tout ce qui a été
proposé d' un peu innovante a été
balayée d'un revers de main par le
gouvernement et le président de la
république alors qu'on est face à une
crise sans précédent sur le plan
sanitaire sur le plan environnemental
sur climatique et donc sur le plan
social parce que bien sûr tout est lié
et et il faut qu'on soit en capacité
finalement de proposer dès maintenant
des
mesures qui soient à la hauteur des
défis que nous rencontrons aujourd'hui
et moi quand je regarde la feuille de
route du gouvernement le compte n'y est
pas clairement ni en termes de
propositions ni en termes de financement
c'est un vrai enjeu qui est devant nous
c'est comme en invente un nouveau modèle
pour protéger ce qui aujourd'hui créer
de la souffrance souffrance humaine
souffrance sociale souffrance animale
et puis qui abîme notre planète donc
pour moi l'enjeu aujourd'hui fondamental
il est la crise écologique et crise
sociale sont liés concrètement quels
types de mesures vous pourriez proposé
porter à l'assemblée
on a par exemple évoqué juste avant la
question des passoires thermiques ce qui
s'y fait très chaude vous nous disiez
que c'est une passoire thermique le
problème c'est que la cvo conditions
travail mais c'est les conditions de vie
de milliers de gens dans la
circonscription qui vivent dans des
logements qui bientôt là vont être
qu'ils étaient trop chaud au moment de
la canicule qui vont être des passoires
pour le froid dans quelques semaines et
là il ya un chantier énorme qui est lié
à la question environnementale et à la
qualité de vie des de nos concitoyens
donc là il ya des mesures fortes à
prendre dans ce domaine là philippe
benassaya vous parlez d'une écologie est
responsable et non punitive alors tout
d'abord cette précision pourquoi non
punitive et on va voir avec vous sans
brimer en groupe si vous êtes d'accord
on pas aussi tout simplement parce que
je trouve que l'écologie dans certains
milieux politiques est une idéologie
alors que ça devrait être une thématique
majeure de notre société qui devrait
rassembler droite gauche entre tous les
français sans forcément leur imposer
quelque chose sans débat sans
concertation c'est ça l'écologie
punitive
moi je préfère parler d'écologie
partager responsable incitative
c'est ce qu'ont fait un petit pot
quotidien pause rien moi dans ma ville
je dis pas on va faire si on va faire ça
c'est comme ça je dramatise pas la
situation
je ne dis pas que tout va mal que la
planète va très très très mal il y a des
problèmes on a parlé de sécurité on
parle d'environnement c'est des deux
grandes thématiques de la société
d'aujourd'hui et j'espère que c'est
interchangeables c'est de vous pouvez
parler sécurité je peux parler
d'environnement et vice versa la
sécurité n'appartient pas à la droite
cette écologie et la gauche porte
heureusement mais voilà c'est ça que je
dis l'écologie aujourd'hui elle est un
petit peu comment dirais-je captée par
des courants politiques qui font
ceux de cette écologie une idéologie et
je trouve que c'est regrettable pour le
pays écologie punitive ou non punitive
moi je pense que ce qui est punitif
c'est les familles qui doivent par
exemple emmener leur aux urgences où un
gamin parce qu'ils sont en crise
d'asthme c'est la question de des
pubertés précoces parce qu'on allait
perturbateur endocrinien qui sont se
sont multipliées dans notre
environnement saas et punitifs pour les
familles et c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que modifier ce modèle là quand on
est dans un système où le libéralisme
peut se développer sans jamais être
régulée et sans que la puissance
publique intervient justement pour
réguler un certain nombre de
propositions et faire des propositions
on ne peut pas s'en sortir
dire que pour moi c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est politiquement un courant
qui y est liée à la gauche parce que si
on a un capitalisme débridé et un
système libéral qui n'est pas contrôlée
ce qui est plutôt le projet de droite on
va dire on ne peut pas avoir des actions
fortes dans le domaine environnemental
voilà madame ce que je reproche qu'on
fait à l'effet à l'écologie c'est d'en
faire une une écologie politicienne
idéologie confisqué par la gauche pour
accéder un peu le pouvoir c'est
peut-être la dernière carte que vous
allez sortir pour sauver la gauche
moi je trouve que l'écologie doit être
une thématique totalement partagé et
concrète
moi je suis maire d'une ville j'ai été
élu sur un programme environnemental
alors que mon prédécesseur socialiste a
été battu sur un programme du tout
allure ben moi je fais l'écologie
concrètes jamais leur l'air
la qualité des bâtiments la qualité
énergétique je fais des pistes cyclables
je vais planter deux mille arbres je
fais attention à la facture énergétique
je me lance dans un gros projet de smart
cities de ville innovante pour essayer
justement de réduire les coûts et
réduire un petit peu le le gaspillage je
ne parle pas le libéralisme je ne pars
pas de socialisme je ne parle pas de
j'ai l'impression que au delà de
l'écologie il y a cette de lutte quand
même au fond cette lutte entre la
société un petit peu capitaliste et
bourgeoise que vous dénoncez je trouve
qu'il ne faut pas justement kidnappé
l'écologie pour régler vos comptes avec
la société libérale
non je crois qu'on est là vous n'est pas
du tout sur le même registre moi je
parle des problèmes concrets libéralisme
oui mais parce que comment donner on
appartient des familles politiques et
votre famille politique est plutôt une
famille comme solberg
défendez le projet libéral c'est pas en
soi une asus nichols et je pense que
c'est incompatible avec ce que l'on doit
apporter aujourd'hui comme proposition
où l'état doit être un acteur qui va
réguler qui va s'agit pas d'être punitif
il s'agit d'être incitatif il s'agit
d'aller dans un sens et c'est la
puissance publique qui doit faire sa une
ville toute seule je pense qu'elle peut
pas régler tous ces problèmes et c'est
là où le législateur et le rôle de
député doit être important pour porter
une voix forte sur 7 sur ces questions
là abandonné si vous êtes député si je
suis député on va pas siéger dans les
mêmes groupes et les groupes en question
ils vont pas porter les mêmes projets
non qu et c'est là où je pense qu'un
vrai choix qui ce qui se pose et je
pense que la parole de la famille
politique qui est la mienne est plus
crédible sur ces questions parce que on
a des projets concrets je vous l'avais
dit la dernière fois mais nous par
exemple on est pour qu'on puisse
promouvoir la production locale
d'énergies propres
ça c'est le législateur qui peut le
porter en parce que si on laisse faire
ce qu'il se passera jamais rien il y
aura six quelques tentatives comme ça a
été fait à grigny mais il faut
abandonner que ce soit un projet qui
soit porté de manière globale sur
l'ensemble du pays pour sortir des
situations on est aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'il faut
écoutez et regardez de bonne pratique du
terrain l'état peut faire beaucoup de
choses on va parler sécurité on parle
d'environnement on va l'état peut parler
de social peut faire beaucoup de choses
mais je trouve qu'il faut quand même
regarder ce que font les élus locaux et
ce sont les locaux de mer qui font
souvent bouger les choses et peut-être
plus vite que l'état quand vous voyez
les programmes politiques d'ailleurs de
deux élus locaux qu'ils soient de droite
ou de gauche d'ailleurs on se rend
compte que la le volet écologique est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui on est
on est jugé par nos concitoyens non plus
sur pas que mais non plus sur le
développement économique sur l'emploi ou
sur le haut sur le social on est
maintenant jugé sur notre capacité à
transformer la vie et à transformer la
ville et enfers d'une ville grise une
ville verte c'est pas moi c'est pas de
gauche c'est pas libéral s'est pas
laissée pas c'est rien du tout c'est
juste du concret c'est juste quelque
chose qui intéresse tout le monde et je
crois qu'il faut rester là dessus parce
que lorsqu'on va lorsqu'on y biologiste
rôle écologie ont fait de cette écologie
une écologie punitive et souvent
caricaturale et c'est le cas souvent à
gauche je pars je vais pas vous donner
tous les exemples c'est pas vous hein
bien sûr mais j'ai pas vous donner tous
les exemples de l'écologie capture
caricatural qui nous embête un peu au
quotidien quand même concrètement
position un point très précis je siège à
la région dans l'opposition nous on
pense qu'il faut développer tout ce qui
est éco mobilité et vous avez parlé des
pistes cyclables sa demande des
investissements extrêmement lourd et
fille sauf que ce que moi je vois de la
politique de valérie pécresse c'est que
elle a plutôt privilégié depuis qu'elle
arrivait le développement de deux des
projets d'infrastructures routières et
tout ce qui lie à la voiture donc on a
bien deux modèles qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas les mêmes donc on est bien sur
deux de vision de comment on doit
évoluer
demain juste un point sur vos temps de
parole respectifs sandrine grands
groupes quatre minutes 22 filets
benassaya 3 minutes 30 et nous avait un
tout petit peu plus d'avancé pour rester
sur cette thématique d'environnement
d'écologie à une question d'actualité
aujourd'hui qui revient assez souvent
c'est la question de la 5g par exemple
si vous êtes élu député
l'un ou l'autre peut-être aurez-vous à
vous prononcer faut-il un moratoire ou
non philippe benassaya comme vous avez
un peu plus de retard je commençais avec
vous la 5g
est-ce qu'il faut un moratoire est ce
qu'il faut suspendre est-ce que c'est
dangereux quel regard portez-vous par
exemple sur cette question voilà sujet
idéologique c'est à dire que je suis
persuadé que vous allez proposer un
moratoire ou peut-être vous opposer à
l'assemblée je ne sais pas vous mais
vous allez le dire moi je trouve qu'on a
pris du retard par rapport aux autres
pays européens
vous prenez vite elle il prenait
l'espagne vous prenez l'autriche
l'allemagne ils se sont déjà lancés avec
la 5g avec des études en faisant
attention et en regardant ce que c'est
nous en france on n'a rien fait c'est un
peu comme les ogm c'est un peu comme
toutes les autres tous les autres sujets
on bloque par idéologie est forcément
prend du retard
on a pris du retard surtout d'ailleurs
sur tous les autres sujets politiques
c'est pas c'est pas ni vous ni moi sur
tous les autres sujets politiques on
prend du retard sur la crise sanitaire
en a pris du retard sur l'as angie on
prend au prend du retard
c'est c'est un mal français qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une bien pensants
sous-conseiller team bloquent souvent
lorsqu'on doit se développer et apporter
des services supplémentaires aux
français
c'est sur ce suivi les pas de moratoire
vous en pouvoir le développement de la
5g si dans votre commune est vraiment
d'en installer
c'est déjà plus rare c'est déjà là mais
prenez prenais ma commune on est en
train de voir si je le reprenne un
simple on est en train d'installer à 5 g
ça fait depuis six mois que je travaille
dessus pour voir comment ça se passe
j'essaye de faire parler des
connaisseurs je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la 5 j essaie de voir le
beau et le mauvais et je prendrai ma
décision donc en tant que responsable
local sandrine grande candidat de
génération dans ce scrutin pour les
législatives je leur précise pour les
auditeurs de radio sensations qui nous
écoutent également sur le 5 g vous êtes
favorable à un moratoire gens aiment
bien un développement plus rapide
il ya une parole politique qui était de
dire on me débats avant de décider
c'était le la question était posée au
moment de la convention citoyenne sur
l'environnement le président s'était
engagé à débattre moi j'attends le débat
pour qu'on puisse se prononcer et
franchement
moi j'aimerais bien que avant qu'on
parle de la 5g on est par exemple la
fibre partout dans sur votre territoire
je pense que là il ya des
investissements à faire qui nous on est
très très en retard j'aimerais bien que
toutes les écoles de trappes n'ait pas à
subir des problèmes de connexion comme
c'est le cas de manière systématique
donc avant de se lancer dans des grands
projets qui à mon avis correspondent à
des demandes aussi d'entreprises qui ne
sont pas forcément en lien avec ce qui
se passe directement sur le terrain
allons au bout de ce qu'on a commencé
moi j'aimerais bien que la finale arrive
partout sur 50 ans du lean et sur le
canton de saint ciers alors venez à bois
d'arcy parce qu'on a la fibre la visite
de chance oui de la chance mais c'est
vrai que là où joue là je plaisantais
mais là où vous avez raison c'est que
c'est vrai d'abord c'est très lent
d'installer la fibre on a mis à peu près
de trois ans installer la fibre à bois
d'arcy c'est c'est compliqué il ya des
travaux de génie il ya énormément de
problèmes de riverains des problèmes de
sécurité il faut faire attention il ya
des écoles
il ya plein de choses donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas un sujet facile la fille
c'est vrai qu'il faut y aller
probablement peut-être par étapes de
terminer la fibre et peut-être se lancer
dans la salle il ya pas de précis des
précipitations je lisais juste qu'on est
en retard par rapport aux autres pays
européens
mais qu'il faut régler le problème les
uns après les autres vous êtes quasiment
à égalité de temps de parole cinq
minutes 10 pour tous philippe benassaya
cinq minutes 12 pour sandrine legrand
parfait merci continuons comme ça
parlons de sécurité à présent puisque
nous aurons quasiment la moitié déjà de
ce débat sécurité le président emmanuel
macron annoncé début septembre vouloir
faire de la lutte contre les violences
là aussi sa priorité délinquance
harcèlement de rue drogue ou encore
séparatisme il ya plusieurs mesures qui
ont été ou qui vont être annoncées
pendant ce temps ce qu'on appelle le
sentiment d'insécurité en tout cas ne
fait que grandir parmi la population
alimentée par des faits divers début de
semaine encore une jeune femme a été
insulté et frappé par trois hommes pour
avoir tout simplement porter une robe
dans les rues de strasbourg philippe
benassaya vous qui êtes candidat pour
l'élu républicain est soutenu par votre
votre famille de droite pour vous la
réponse à cette situation ces autorités
et fermeté alors oui c'est un peu un peu
raccourcie mais vous avez raison d'abord
la sécurité et le sujet majeur qui
préoccupent les français aujourd'hui
alors voilà on essayait là aussi de
sortir des carcans idéologiques on
essaie d'être concret
quand on parle de sécurité c'est la
première de nos libertés il n'y a pas de
sécurité sans liberté n'y a pas de
liberté sans sécurité
je veux dire par là c'est qu'aujourd'hui
ce pays n'est plus tenu sentiment
d'insécurité comme vous l'avez dit
sentiment d'impunité laxisme pénale les
peines ne sont pas appliquées ou quand
elles soient appliquées elles sont
remises rapidement voilà donc il y à il
y a quand même un vrai sujet et puis il
ya des violences à l'égard des forces de
l'ordre des violences à l'égard des
familles des jeunes filles dans les
quartiers des jeunes hommes la réponse
c'est un peu du blabla de la barre du
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de blabla je
ne vois pas encore aujourd'hui ce que le
gouvernement assez je pense qu'il y à un
changement radical de système adopté en
matière de sécurité c'est à dire qu'il
faut rétablir l'ordre républicain
l'ordre républicain sur tout le
territoire français
c'est à dire qu'il faut que les peines
soient adoptés il faut donner plus de
moyens à la police
il faut il faut donner plus de moyens je
pense qu'on sera pas d'accord avec vos
polices municipales il faut donner des
moyens aussi aux élus locaux pour qu'ils
puissent installer dans leur commune
installé dans l'eure dans leur
collectivité des caméras de la
vidéoprotection moi je vois sur bois
d'arcy la vidéoprotection nous a fait
baisser considérablement le taux de
délinquance sur la ville qui presque
presque minimes
donc il y a des solutions il ya beau il
ya beaucoup de choses et puis il ya
également
je voudrais le dire beaucoup de tensions
identitaires dans ce pays donc la
réponse ne va être que par des du
dialogue que par des conférences que par
des des voix là il faut aussi être
beaucoup plus ferme et beaucoup plus
fermes sur nos valeurs républicaines
ferme sur la laïcité est ferme sur les
skis fait la france est ce qui fait les
valeurs de la république fermeté
également lors du premier débat que nous
avions organisé vous nous aviez expliqué
pour vous la question de la sécurité et
est allié avec la question des services
publics aussi d'un manque de moyens
oui pour moi c'est indissociable de la
question des services publics comment
notre état et permet d'avoir un certain
nombre de services qui sont absolument
indispensable pour une vie en société
la sécurité est un droit fondamental et
donc le droit à la sécurité est et doit
être le même partout qu'on habite
inversa et qu'on habite à trappes qu'on
habite à rambouillet et c'est pour ça
que je pense que l'état ne joue pas son
rôle et il ne joue pas son rôle depuis
un certain nombre d'années et moi je le
regrette
on lui dit tout le temps mais c'est une
réalité allez me dire que c'est encore
idéologique mais que dans les mesures
que nicolas sarkozy avait prises à
l'époque c'était la suppression de plus
de onze mille policiers un moment donné
on a besoin d'avoir sur le terrain des
gens qui sont réactifs et je vous le
disais au premier débat mais sur la
circonscription du commissariat
d'elancourt
la nuit on a pour cent soixante dix
mille habitants
trois patrouilles donc évidemment que ça
va pas et qu'il faut des forces
supplémentaires sur le terrain
donc pour que ça marche il faut il faut
de la présence humaine il faut qu' il y
ait des recrutements et on ne peut pas
avoir des gens qui sont souffrance qui
appelle le 17
parce qu'il ya des nuisances sonores
parce que des fois des choses plus
graves et qui attendent attendent
attendent et qui n'ont pas de réponse
parce que ça crée ce sentiment
d'insécurité
et puis dans les cas les plus graves
c'est parfois trop tard donc moi je suis
vraiment persuadé que si on n'est pas
les moyens en terme de présence humaine
on s'en sortira pas mais est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi rien qu'en grande
que pour renforcer les moyens il faut
donner des moyens sur le terrain c'est à
dire en matière d'innovation numérique
par exemple est-ce que vous allez
soutenir si vous êtes député le
commissariat du futur le d'elancourt est
ce que vous êtes et ce que vous êtes
pour le déploiement de la
vidéoprotection est ce que vous êtes
pour le renforcement de la police
municipale j'ai pas l'impression
je ne peux pas c'est le premier point le
commissariat du futur si c'est pas du
gadget
oui parce que pour l'instant moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
gadgets et de communication je veux voir
ce qu'est ce qu'il ya de concret n 3
roger doit voir le jour sur la ville
d'elancourt et c'est un commissariat de
sérieux
coincé importe réellement quelque chose
pour de la c1 commissariat qui
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
d'abord des locaux qu'ils soient
effectivement digne pour accueillir nos
policiers je crois que c'est déjà la
priorité sur les polices municipales il
ya une police municipale à trappes
on va renforcer ses effectifs parce que
clairement il n'y a pas assez de
policiers municipaux pour intervenir le
soir et le week-end et sur la
vidéoprotection la vidéosurveillance en
fonction de je pense que c'est un outil
mais un outil parmi d'autres et qui ne
remplace pas là encore la présence
humaine dans des lieux stratégiques
ça peut être un élément de sécurisation
on sait très bien que malheureusement là
vous mettez des caméras vous déplacer
souvent en fait les problèmes de
délinquance donc c'est pas une solution
afin qu'ils soient en soi miraculeuse et
ouais mais la vidéo protection est là
elle a un autre lien en amont comme en
aval c'est-à-dire que vous créez des
centres de supervision urbain avec la
vidéoprotection c'est à dire moi j'en ai
créé un compte et le fleury j'en ai créé
un vélizy dans le terme de versailles
grand parc le centre de supervision vous
permet de voir en globalité sur des sur
des sur des écrans ce qui se passe dans
les villes
même quand ça se déplace comme vous le
dites je pense que le renforcement des
moyens humains est important mais aussi
il faut que les moyens soient aussi
innovant la police de demain faut la
créer c'est pas la police dit hier qu'il
faut renforcer la police de demain et la
police de demain c'est maintenant les
outils numériques qui sont à la
disposition de toutes les grandes
démocraties temps si vous voyez sur les
écrans qui a un agression qui est en
train de se passer et que vous avez
personnes a envoyé sur place ça c'était
la sépareront pas et si vous faites des
écoles et des classes en passant
enseignants ça marchera pas d'où là
c'est actuellement laricio vikings je
vous dis il ya celle l'amont et l'aval
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut qui est à la
fois le renforcement des moyens
et puis aussi le renforcement de
l'arsenal juridique moi je suis
favorable à l'abaissement de la majorité
pénale à 16 ans je suis pour plus de
places de prison j'ai une maison d'arrêt
quand même un preneur 6,6 en place ou
deux sont détenus
il ya un problème en france 2 des
maisons d'arrêt donc là aussi je suis
plus favorable a dit me ou 1 15 mai
place de prison en plus en france pour
pouvoir justement ne pas ne pas rester
sur cet état de fait qui est quand même
dramatique en france
tanner être élu député l'un ou l'autre
parmi les propositions vous pourriez
faire est ce que ce serait aussi de
conférer plus de pouvoir ou non aux
mères et je reviens sur la question de
la police municipale pour gérer ces
problèmes là où est ce qu'on est
vraiment dans un problème régalien et
c'est l'état uniquement qui doit
intervenir sans s'appuyer sur les élus
locaux ils sont quand même je pose la
question premier vous avez une trente
secondes de retard je pense que c'est il
faut forcément quand on discute entre à
tous les échelons ça ne marche que comme
ça et on voit bien le rôle essentiel du
préfet que dans la relation qu'il a avec
les maires avec les élus qui est à la
fois je rappelle que le maire il est
aussi le représentant de l'état quand il
a les deux et là ils allaient les deux
casquettes
donc pour moi c'est tout ça est en
complémentarité il peut pas y avoir un
état de déconnecter mais il faut qu'il
ya un état puissant et qui assume son
rôle est ce qu'on est dans la non du
régalien on est dans des pouvoirs qui et
quand je disais que je souhaite que ce
soit par tous la même sécurité qu'on
soit à trappes temps soit à versailles
c'est aussi parce que je ne veux pas que
en données en fonction du maire qu'on
aura ou des choix politiques correcteurs
qui auront été faits on ait l'impression
qu'on est en sécurité un endroit et pas
à l'autre ça c'est du ressort de l'état
a contrario lorsqu'il y a des villes de
gauche parfois peut-être il y à une
régression dans les moyens et dans et
dans les vidéo protection ou ou dans le
pouvoir que peuvent avoir les maires en
matière de sécurité
moi je pense que et je vous le dis très
honnêtement est-ce que la sécurité reste
aujourd'hui un pouvoir régalien de
l'état
si c'est oui moi je revenais je redonne
tout à l'état moi j'ai investi
énormément en matière de police
municipale de de renforcement des moyens
de vidéoprotection de sang de
supervision si les toits l'état doit
régler le problème de la sécurité
j'aurai donc tout je me fais rembourser
mais ça sera pas le cas aujourd'hui
l'état se désengage on certaines parties
de la sécurité pourquoi parce que l'état
estime et peut-être que j'espère que
pour les problèmes de santé ce sera la
même chose dans l'avenir l'état estime
que peut-être pour régler certains
problèmes ensemble état et collectivités
peut-être qu'il faut faire descendre un
petit peu les points là les problèmes de
sécurité et donné un petit peu plus de
pouvoirs aux élus locaux et aux mères
c'est ce qu'on fait ça marche plutôt
bien
maintenant c'est partagé par les trappes
tout à l'heure nous avons une police
municipale attrape moi aussi
j'en ai une sacyr l'école fonte mail en
cours bien évidemment donc voilà donc je
pense que c'est une révolution de l'état
d'esprit qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'on va aller sur certains
sujets comme la sécurité ou la santé
vers un état beaucoup plus décentralisée
c'est comme si vous souhaitez répondre
si vous avez une petite minute de retard
et après on passera en conclusion non
mais je reviens sur la question des
services publics parce que il s'agit pas
de dire l'état fait tout ne fait rien on
est on est bien sûr de la
complémentarité mais un moment donné il
ya un certain nombre de sujets où c'est
l'état qui doit jouer son rôle au parce
qu'aussi on va jusqu'au bout alors ça
sera dans quelques temps les les maires
qui vont payer les professeurs des
écoles
je pense qu'il ya des sujets sur
lesquels il faut que l'état joue son
rôle et parce qu'il ya aussi des
problématiques d'aménagement vous
parliez du commercial commissariat
d'elancourt la question de comment on
implante légué où on apporte les
commissariats quels moyens on mais il
faut que ça soit abandonnée non pas de
la responsabilité des élus locaux mais
bien de l'état
donc la question des services publics
elle et moi je j'aime bien cette phrase
qui dit que les services publics c'est
le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
dire qu'il faut aussi avoir en tête que
les plus fragiles ont besoin d'un état
qui les protège nous passons la
conclusion de ce débat du second tour
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
philippe benassaya vous avez une minute
pour conclure non mais tout simplement
on va pas faire des grandes conclusions
type médias nationaux pour cette
élection c'est une élection j'espère
qu'il aura beaucoup plus de
participation qu'au premier tour ça
c'est un grand élément démocratique
important et puis c'est une île et son
capital c'est une élection législative
c'est-à-dire qu'on envoie pardonnez
l'expression d'un député à l'assemblée
nationale pour représenter des
concitoyens c'est à dire pour
représenter plus de cent vingt mille
habitants la circonscription
je pense que pour envoyer après la
voiture hasardeuse qu'on est dans la 2e
circonscription vu comment ça s'est
terminé avec un suppléant mise en examen
je pense qu'il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux
d'ailleurs on est revenu un peu aux
fondamentaux dans le duel droite gauche
très honnêtement et pourquoi
tout simplement parce que je pense qu'il
ya un avant et un après qu vide je pense
que des concitoyens et nous a aidé les
français ont vu que pendant les crises
sanitaires sociales ou économiques qui
entrevue aujourd'hui des élus locaux
ils ont vu des gens qui se bougeait qui
distribue des masques qui qui qui
dépensait l'argent pour des gels pour la
dispensation pour nettoyer les écoles et
je pense c'est cela qui
la france aujourd'hui c'est cette france
d'en bas ces élus locaux qui monte pour
porter les bonnes pratiques et pour être
les porte parole de des belles
initiatives locales que développent les
élus locaux les acteurs les chefs
d'entreprise les artisans et les
associations et je veux être le porte
parole de ces de ces personnes là c'est
à vous de conclure vous avez une minute
trente pour assurer l'égalité et puis
vous parlez de participation tout à
l'heure effectivement je leur précise 16
% seulement des électeurs qui ont
participé à ce scrutin
c'est évidemment un scrutin qui est
important parce qu'on les concitoyens
vont envoyer un message fort qui et quel
type de politique ils veulent
demain que l'on défende à l'assemblée
nationale moi je souhaitais était une
députée utile sûr qu'il soit en capacité
de proposer des des lois de voter des
lois qui vont dans le sens d'une
amélioration de la vie quotidienne des
gens on n'a pas beaucoup parlé du local
à aider il ya des dossiers parce qu'on
n'avait pas le temps mais il ya des
dossiers locaux qu'il faut porter aussi
qui concerne le logement qui concerne
des projets qui sont en cours la
nationale 10 à trappes
mais il ya plein d'autres de ce type il
faut quelqu'un ancré sur le territoire
qui connaît ses dossiers et qui les
porte à l'assemblée et je pense que les
enjeux qui sont devant nous sont
tellement importants que il faut
réinterroger notre modèle cela crise
sanitaire vous en avez parlé la crise
écologique aller devant nous s'agit pas
d'être alarmiste il s'agit juste de dire
les choses est de proposer un modèle de
développement qui permettra à la fois
d'avoir les propositions écologistes et
qui permettent la solidarité merci à
vous d'avoir participé à ce débat 15
secondes près vous êtes à égalité merci
encore merci aux téléspectateurs de tv
78 aux auditeurs de radio sensations
également et n'oubliez donc pas si vous
résidez sur les communes de bois d'arcy
des longs cours de fontenay le fleury la
verrière le mesnil saint denis saint cyr
l'école ou encore trappe le second tour
de l'élection législative partielle sur
la 11e circonscription donc se déroule
ce 27 septembre
à très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]